粉絲說你眼睛
怎麼這麼好
這字那麼小
你都看得很清楚
我之所以能夠
不費力的看小字
是因為我有個
保養眼睛的秘訣
而且這個秘訣做了以後
還能夠幫助你
改善老花近視
以及眼睛的痠痛
你學起來的話
絕對是一生受用
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
70歲看小字好清楚
5穴救老花近視
來喔 馬上跟你說
我到了70歲
不用戴老花眼鏡的秘密
就是這一招
把手這樣捲起來
哎 美麗的太太
你跟我一起做好嗎
好啊
把手這樣捲起來
然後放在你的眼眶上面
有幾個穴道
攢竹
魚腰
瞳子髎
承泣
睛明
就這幾個穴呢
常常這樣子
揉一揉 揉一揉
就這樣揉
就這樣揉一揉
要揉多久
大概一兩分鐘
兩三分鐘都可以
我們再按一次
這裡眉頭
攢竹
魚腰
然後再來邊邊
瞳子髎
還有眼睛下方
這個叫做
承泣
另外在鼻子的兩邊
眼睛的內側
這個叫做睛明
就這樣子
做一次再做兩次做三次
因為有點痛
所以也不要做太長時間
只是點到為止的
這樣做一做
我跟你講
將來你的眼睛
就跟我差不多了
黃帝內經裡頭說
五臟六腑之精氣
皆上注於目
意思就是你的精氣
你的氣血
都會供應到眼睛去
所以你的眼睛好不好
也應對著你的身體的狀況
你如果長時間
盯著螢幕或者是看股票
看的眼睛都痠痛
趕快按摩
這個地方一兩圈
就這樣子按一按
已經有老花的人
也能夠透過按摩
來改善你的眼睛
這個地方的循環
而且能夠
延緩你的眼睛的老化退化
很讚喔
回家可以教
阿公阿嬤
爸爸媽媽
全家一起按起來
最棒天然眼藥
每天一小把
5天抗眼乾
美麗的太太 你知道嗎
台灣乾眼症的人
有六百萬人
意思就是說辦公室裡頭
10個人
就有2-3個人
眼睛乾乾的澀澀的
天天要滴點眼藥水
才可以喔
我跟你說
有一個很棒的
天然眼藥
1週就能讓你緩解
眼睛乾澀
它就是枸杞這個東西
研究證實中年健康的人
每週吃5天
1次1小把
連續吃那個90天
黃斑色素密度
立刻的
上升明顯
並且保護視網膜的效果
比吃補充品
還要更棒喔
動物上面的實驗
都證明了
吃了枸杞的萃取物
牠的眼淚的量也會增加
角膜損傷也減少了
甚至於改善了乾眼症
怎麼吃枸杞最有效呢
我教你兩招
第一招 上班族當零食吃
是最方便喔
抓幾個枸杞咚咚吃下去
當零食來吃
嘴巴裡面
還不會覺得不舒服
眼睛乾 疲勞都能夠舒緩
一定有人會問
枸杞一天能吃幾顆呀
吃一小把
大概十幾二十顆吧
第二招 枸杞菊花決明子一起泡
枸杞 決明子 菊花
一起泡著來喝
幫助眼睛血液的循環
一週就能感受到
眼睛變得水亮的
非常舒服
買決明子的時候
有個秘訣
我建議你到
中藥房買的時候呢
買生的 買炒的各一半
生的跟炒的
為什麼呢
因為生的可以幫助
瀉一點點火
幫助排便也很好
因為這樣不容易上火
也能改善血脂肪
幫助眼睛的血液循環
接下來我們請小芬示範怎麼泡
枸杞菊花決明子茶
我們來泡一個
準備材料有三種
枸杞5克
菊花3克
決明子5克
你將全部的材料呢
放入杯子或是茶壺中
再倒入300~500cc的熱水
燜泡15分鐘
就能喝囉
那枸杞怎麼
分辨好和壞呢
最重要的
你不要只是看這一個
你看它的這個蒂頭
這蒂頭有沒有跟這個
枸杞的顏色完全一樣的
這種你不要買
那個就是染色的
枸杞有它的橙色對不對
那上面那個蒂頭呢
應該是比它的顏色要淡
有點白色的
那這就不是染色
而是天然就是那樣子的
還有那個太紅太漂亮
可能聞起來還有點酸味的
那就不要買
要選顆粒大 沒有農藥
沒有防腐劑
沒有色素
還是有機認證的
吃得安心又有效
不是手機
2習慣
讓孩子近視飆高
有些媽媽說
她都不讓小孩滑手機了
怎麼還是近視
其實近視的主要原因
不是螢幕
而是長時間近距離來用眼睛
像是距離不到3公尺看電視
或者距離不到30公分
寫字 讀書
這些才是
真正讓眼睛
吃不消的原因
孩子容易近視
常常都是
兩個習慣養成的
握筆的方式
讀書的姿勢
我們先講小朋友握筆
來寫字怎麼寫
我們現在看到小孩
太小的時候
就開始學習寫字
大概讀幼稚園
或者是才三歲五歲
媽媽就說
你拿個筆畫個圖
寫個字啊
你知道小孩子的手沒有力
拿起筆來啊
這樣才有力啊
這樣寫
這樣寫的時候
你看眼睛看不見
所以呢
你必須眼睛這樣子
歪下去看
那假如說
你能夠改變這個習慣
就像我這樣子寫字就好了
可是小孩子沒力啊
他拿起來就是那樣子
那麼這樣子的話
眼睛就太近距離
看所畫的東西
所寫的東西
還有呢
讀書的時候
有的時候頭會累啊
就這樣子讀書
這樣子讀書的話
眼睛就偏了
對不對
離那個紙太近了
我小的時候啊
我爸爸教我寫字啊
那個光線從
左前方這樣下來
然後呢他叫我
把這個頭就一定是這樣子
這樣寫
眼睛要離那個字距呢
大約25-30公分
這樣才好
所以我一直到現在
都還受益於這個
所以假如說
你家有小孩子
還很小呢
你也學習我這樣子
將來他到了80歲
仍然眼睛非常的好
1動作放鬆睫狀肌
防近視度數
往上狂飆
美麗的太太
你知道現在的孩子
近視真的是越來越早了
對不對
是啊
幼兒園大班的近視小孩呢
就快有一成
10個人裡頭就有1個
小學一年級的時候
就飆到兩成
六年級的時候更誇張
直接到七成之多
這麼小就近視
還要戴眼鏡
這樣不是很難過
來來來
我教你一個簡單的方法
準備一支筆
就像我手上這樣
有一支筆
你拿著這個筆呢
練習看遠看近
怎麼做你知道嗎
把這個筆放在這裡
看得清楚嗎
很清楚
然後呢慢慢慢慢拉遠
也一定看得很清楚
看得很清楚
然後從遠拉近的時候
看得很清楚吧
就是這個焦距
就一直放在這個筆上
然後拉近拉近拉近
拉到最近
就再拉遠一點
然後漸漸的拉遠
漸漸的拉遠
你常常這樣練習
就可以一直看得
有一個距離看東西
這樣眼睛
就不容易得近視了
做這個剛講的筆尖
近遠近遠的訓練呢
就像幫眼睛
做一個伸展操
它一下子拉直 一下放鬆
一下拉直 一下放鬆
這樣子的話呢
就使眼睛做了
伸展運動了
把僵硬的肌肉放鬆開來
讓睫狀肌非常的靈活
度數就不會快速加深
甚至於已經近視的人
你常常做這種訓練
也很好
我們小編他近視500度
他還透過這樣子的訓練時間呢
大概將近一年了
看遠方比以前 他說清楚好多
那我們去打
羽毛球 棒球
眼睛一直來回看
那是不是也可以啊
當然
研究顯示啊
每週多一小時的戶外運動
近視的風險就降低2%
相反的
每週多滑一小時的手機
近視風險你知道多少
就增加6個百分點
所以呢
帶著孫子
去戶外動一動
才是預防近視眼的最好方法
不只是眼睛變好
感情也變得更親密哦
那不是一兼二顧
一兼二顧
摸蜊仔兼洗褲
哈哈哈
我台語講得準不準
愛喝即溶咖啡傷眼
3食物也少吃
我跟你說啊
有一個東西會傷眼
就是即溶咖啡
我們以前吃了很多的即溶咖啡
好
研究顯示呢
他說習慣於喝即溶咖啡的人
眼睛黃斑病變的風險
竟然比一般人高多少
你知道嗎
7倍
啊
即溶咖啡會傷眼睛哦
即溶咖啡在製造的過程當中
會產生兩種有害物質
丙烯醯胺和糖化的終產物
它們會讓視網膜產生氧化壓力
慢性發炎
久了就容易造成眼睛細胞的退化
而在台灣呢
黃斑部並變其實是很常見的
65歲以上的人
大概每十個裡頭就有一個
所以愛喝即溶咖啡的人
建議你不要
天天喝
除了即溶咖啡
這3種食物也會傷眼
第1種 高糖食物
加速眼睛老化
血管的損傷
第2種 高脂肪食物
讓血液的黏稠度增加
眼睛的血液循環就變不好了
第3種 冰冷的食物
冰品 生魚片等等
中醫認為吃冰品就不好
那我們用現在的觀念
來講的話呢
會收縮血管 氣血不暢
氣血不暢
讓眼睛不要太寒涼
很重要
像我自己也用蒸氣眼罩
來放鬆我的眼睛呢
第二步才是進補的方法
護眼睛你可以吃
含葉黃素 蝦紅素的食物
有葉黃素的食物有什麼呢
像深綠色的蔬菜
例如菠菜 綠花椰菜
幫助你吸收藍光
保護你的黃斑部
蝦紅素的食物
例如鮭魚 蝦子等等
這些海鮮
消除眼睛的疲勞抗氧化
不是只有不滑手機
不是只有不看近物
而是連食物你都得要注意哦